[Música]
mobilidade afetiva outra cidade é
possível
já morei em vários lugares do brasil é
do norte eu sou eu quem sou gaúcho humor
em mais de dez cidades
aí nosso nosso trabalho na na teoria é
basicamente é o reconhecimento do local
então conhecemos profundamente findado
vivenciamos a cidade tem um processo
heurístico que vivenciar a cidade
estamos influenciada por ela já viajei
diversas partes do país bicicleta ea
parte mais chata de você chegar no
destino
uma parte mais ampla viagem chega ao
destino e mobilidade efetiva onde o
percurso faz sentido né o percurso da
viagem é uma coisa muito interessante e
sim o destino é quando você não quer
chegar então você sai você faz sempre o
mesmo trajeto de ônibus né pra com o
meio de transporte é o objetivo
transporte é só um meio de ligar a com b
e na viagem de bicicleta ou a pé enfim
diversas tipos locomoção onde você está
no lugar presentemente isso é mobilidade
efetiva então você cria uma relação com
o lugar onde a cada instante você passa
está no lugar
a nossa equipe é muito comprometida essa
equipe do escritório
enfim uma equipe essa minha esposa que a
minha sócia enfim sempre a gente teve
mais de 40 pessoas passaram pelo
escritório
ninguém vai de carro pelo escritório
todos os ciclistas vão aped transporte
coletivo e enfim uma premissa não ir de
carro para o escritório
quem como a maior parte veio aqui todos
de bicicleta para enfim a gente é uma
empresa b onde esse certificado esse
certificado de impacto socioambiental eu
gosto do slogan dessa de certificado que
é um certificado internacional
a gente é a única empresa de
planejamento urbano até certificado é
não somente um queremos ser somente os
melhores do mundo são os melhores para 1
é essa nossa vocação de ser melhor para
o mundo e buscar isso então a gente faz
um planejamento urbano voltado para o
melhor o melhor do mundo é nossa empresa
visa isso com com os nossos processos
além disso a gente é alinhado com um
desafio do desenvolvimento sustentável
com os ads da onu nesse processo de
entender o que é a mobilidade efetiva o
que planejar a cidade planejar-se
deslocamento onde o mais importante não
é chegar e se um percurso onde a gente
cai a ficha quando a gente faz uma
viagem de bicicleta foi o primeiro
momento em que caiu a ficha
eu procurei começar a escrever estudar
fiz no mestrado sobre isso para entender
a mobilidade afetiva o deslocamento e o
processo foi foi eu fui buscando
entender o porquê eu estava trabalhando
conhecendo o que motivava onde eu queria
chegar
então como é filha de três anos e meio
eu comecei a fazer uma horta na frente
de casa no espaço público onde era um
retorno de carro que foi fechado
uma pequena horta que a gente começou a
cuidar eu queria dar uma educação a
sócio ambiental pra ela
enfim a gente começou a aas relacionar
com os vizinhos e com a terra e um dia
com esta horta a gente é el ela é a mãe
dela a gente fez uma refeição só da
horta então a revolução começou com uma
cenoura né
então onde a batata milho a cenoura
tomate tudo que for colhido ali gerou
uma refeição eu falei nossa não preciso
me deslocar né
eu tento na frente de casa tudo no novo
espaço público num terreno de todos
eu fui procurar nesse processo de
entendimento entender a cidade que há
cidade a cidade começou a surgir em 800
grandes cidades com crescimento com
desenvolvimento do capitalismo onde a
população urbana passou rural
recentemente por detrimento deste
processo de crescimento das cidades onde
ao crescimento da desigualdade também
mundial então existe uma íntima relação
das das grandes cidades e do capitalismo
as grandes cidades do século 18 e 19
são cidades onde é muito importante é
você produzir consumir distribuir
armazenar onde a distribuição o espaço
distribuição é muito diferente na cidade
da cidade medieval
você tem a cidade medieval onde não há
uma distribuição a relação em campo
cidade diferente ea cidade
a grande cidade um grande aglomerado com
mais de 1 milhão de habitantes
começa a ser um lugar da peste em
londres no início do século 18 é a maior
cidade do mundo é nova york como essa
ser uma grande cidade com mais de 1
milhão de habitantes
então você tem todo esse processo é de a
cidade ser um lugar que visava a
distribuição de renda mas não acontece e
você começa um processo de deformação de
de espaços desiguais e de de de
armazenamento porque são cidades
subtropicais neoci o capitalismo se
desenvolve na europa e estados unidos
e você tem esse processo de formação da
distribuição nas cidades onde no século
19 que o hino no início do século 20
a urbanista italiano aliado à o prefeito
de los angeles criam modelos subúrbio
americano que você tem conceito
suburbano então em 1901 por volta da da
primeira guerra se cria os subúrbios em
los angeles los angeles já se torna
maior cidade territorialmente no mundo e
daí você criou o conceito pode ter que é
o td trator para fazer o deslocamento
que está cada vez maior no estado então
cada vez você está morando mais longe e
precisa chegar o trabalho então essa
distância não é mais possível fazer de
bicicleta o transporte coletivo não se
espraia tanto
não se tem a densidade que só se fica no
núcleo urbano então você cria
necessidade do carro e esse conceito de
você e diga de de automóveis guerra casa
própria é porque você é um ex combatente
americano não se criou em los angeles
l ele ganha casa própria têm direito a
casa própria depois de ele ter ido à
guerra então por matar a indústria
bélica formentão para o patriotismo
americano
você é incentivar a construção civil
então é uma prova de uma proliferação
das cidades do povoamento territorial
norte-americano não mais só em grandes
cidades mas de maneira mais homogênea
alguma uma proliferação de ocupação do
território como um todo de um grande
país não só em grandes cidades como no
brasil
e você cria exatamente pela pela
expansão das cidades a necessidade do
carro
o carro é uma consequência dessa
necessidade então a gente criou esse
conceito e o carro é no primeiro desenho
é vou falar justamente nesse processo
que acontece com o aumento da velocidade
na via a 20 quilômetros por hora antes
do advento do carro em que o transporte
coletivo uma via que tem uma rua de
terra onde só a calçada calçada em quem
tenho a calçada como proteção da casa
você tem muito mais relação entre os
indivíduos nesses esses pontinhos falam
a relação que cada casa tem cada casa de
cabelo devido à velocidade aumentando
porque a cidade está se espraiando então
você precisa aumentar a velocidade da
via ea potência do motor aumentando é
vai diminuindo a relação entre os
indivíduos da mesma rua então e essa rua
uma hora de uma avenida a calçada se
estreita mais os indivíduos não conhece
praticamente mas ninguém daquela rua
àquela rua se torna um lugar num lugar
de difícil cruzar uma bandeira uma via
de mão dupla uma uma folha de passagem
né ea de passagem para os moradores que
não conhece mais ninguém naquela rua
então esse é um processo que acontece
que o carro faz acontecendo um processo
de desumanização da cidade então é é a
relação da mobilidade afetiva essa
mobília
onde não afetiva na mobilidade do carro
é quando você não tem afeto com um lugar
onde não se relaciona com a cidade se
não se relaciona com os lugares não
funciona com as pessoas
então esse processo precisa ser muito
bem equilibrado a gente quer melhor
lugares e e melhores cidades melhor dos
lugares nos estados unidos
a gente tem praticamente é 800 carros
para mil habitantes
então se existe uma reposição dos carros
não existe mais a venda de carros de
novas novas explosões automobilística
dos estados unidos como explosões
demográficas né
é você tem uma só uma reposição do
controlo de carro cerca de 800 carros a
cada mil habitantes na europa com
transporte coletivo com essa relação
também surge uma reposição já que tem
melhor transporte coletivo nas grandes
cidades é você
no interior você usa muito carro na
europa e no brasil parece que é um
processo evolutivo disso né mas na
verdade é uma desigualdade social onde
se tem mais transporte coletivo porque
gostei propriamente não copiou o modelo
igualmente que foi implantado nos países
envolvidos subtropicais onde existia
esse ciclo virtuoso na guerra carro casa
própria onde no morro da providência a
primeira favela do brasil rio de janeiro
os ex-combatentes a primeira guerra
foram pedir providência da casa própria
que nunca foi dado
então você tem essa relação diretamente
você copia o modelo em dois países que
estão acima do do sub tropicais são os
países frios né que tem três meses do
ano 36 meses do ano de escassez
climática
você copie este modelo é não não copiar
o modelo integralmente então você tem um
problema você aumenta a desigualdade
social pelo desempenho setorial e
urbanismo passa a ser uma uma ferramenta
de inclusão social onde as cidades mais
carro crato as cidades mais excludentes
porque o carro passa a ser uma questão
de poder econômico
então o que eu quero dizer com isso que
uma porcentagem é menor que a metade da
população mora no no território enquanto
legal né no territórios é tropical só a
índia o brasil moram é são os grandes
países é de demora população nesse nessa
parte do do do planeta
esse modelo de urbanização estou
propondo olhar para o território nem
afetivamente como os incas de um cidades
com o machu picchu onde você percorrer a
cidade de 20 minutos você tinha
universidades moradia trabalho colheita
tudo junto você nem precisa inventar a
roda
você tinha tudo junto quem vença o
melhor que há não roda é não inventar a
roda foi muito importante
então estou propondo a gente olhar para
o território de uma forma mais afetiva
com economias locais criatividades e
quem como inter e vina uma das maiores
hortas urbanas do mundo fica em teresina
mas no meu ponto de vista soberba sobre
aproveitada porque ela poderia ser o
magro floresta urbana existe um conceito
de agrofloresta que é aumentar a
produtividade do solo onde muitos
lugares estão fazendo por exemplo em são
paulo perto do largo da batata um posto
de gasolina foi adquirido para virar mar
para a floresta
então é aí a gente criando coletivamente
plantando essas plantas da agrofloresta
disposto gasolina em são paulo para o
largo da batata então é imagina você
indo pegar o metrô colheu uma banana
você tá com fome porque você precisa
enfim você precisa comprar sabão
necessidade oferece tanto para você
então dentro desse conceito a gente tem
um conceito de economia circular
biodiversidade econômica ea gente tem
todo o potencial de desenvolver e isso a
gente pode criar uma nova economia
criativa ligar o território assim como
na na na frança gente né já foi dado o
exemplo do cambulo enfim na frança
episódio muito território cada dia
ligado à montanha uma planície é um novo
planalto vale então tem um dia
específico porque a gente não tenha
goiaba específica de piracicaba ou enfim
o peixe
se fico aqui então olhar para o
território com um afeto
nessa questão do afeto é muito
importante quando você olha
especificamente então a gente
a partir dos do desenvolvimento
sustentável a gente pega os cinco pés
que são os pilares principais e ajuda a
desenvolver essa questão local né então
olhar para o território potencialmente a
gente tem muito mais sol que na europa a
gente pode usar tecnológicamente gente
precisa né de outra fonte de energia que
não só a gente pode desenvolver é uma
uma questão científica é de tecnologias
ligadas à a ao sol que a gente tem
intensamente e de onde vem esse ou não
de bem os recursos hoje é pra por
propiciar e urbanismo tropical das das
dos conjuntos habitacionais periféricos
onde você tem a criação de sistemas
ligados à a cidade então você tem um
sistema de transporte que é muito caro
sistema de esgotos todos os temas
educação você cria sistemas para manter
as pessoas na periferia e que ficam
fazendo esse movimento pendular por
cento isso é extremamente necessário
então a gente poderia ter um brasil
muito mais inclusivo a manter-se as
cidades tradicionais como a gente
conhece hoje ele até outro olhar que a
gente tem um território é muito pouco
povoado por ter outro olhar para o
território e à medida que esse
território vai sendo povoado a gente tem
a fusão dessas duas dessas duas
economias ea diminuição da da da miséria
no país não é que tem é um quarto da
população daí é vive com menos de cinco
dólares 5,5 dólares por dia ea gente em
é consequentemente alcança os objetivos
do desenvolvimento sustentável proposto
pela onu não como prioridade mas com o
olhar para o território então o que a
gente faz é é um urbanismo tropical a a
mobilidade efetiva a gente desenha é um
outro olhar sobre a cidade com
com com potencializando local então a
gente tem exemplos no brasil e no mundo
de como isso acontece né você local
território contra com outra questão onde
o princípio da cidade não passa a ser
mais armazenar da cidade tropical
armazenar e distribuir e sim produzir a
cidade passa a ser produtiva passa a ser
um território produtiva né produtivo em
outra cidade é possível
obrigado
[Aplausos]